how um for you like I feel like
you're still hop like popping in on
people's projects but I feel like the
last like six months or so you've been a
little quiet on like getting on other
people's [__] is it because you're in
album mode yes definitely an album okay
we cooking up I've been on tour hella
you're on tour yeah you feel me so I
went to Australia for the first time how
was we did a run out there Melbourne is
crazy I heard that that's the best city
I've ever been to so far I heard all the
women look like Iggy
I actually hear that and I actually
listen I have friends who have gone
there who are African-American and they
say if you look like us you're getting
all the [__] I can't vouch for a lab
but uh they did treat us like royalty
out here and uh they they just embraced
the LA culture too I feel like they knew
about artists like Kailyn yeah for real
for reals it was a group of girls like
that to me like where Kailyn at really
[__] that's correct that's how they said
it yeah
I can't do the accent but I'm not
feeling a little crazy trying to do it
either is it I heard if you say
Melbourne they get mad it's supposed to
be like Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne
yeah I'll make sure I say it the right
way Jesus put some respect on them so
you were just in Australia living your
best life yeah we did our Australia run
we did like five four or five cities out
there how was the food in Australia is
it the same is it kind of like just
America but like
not I I really don't recall
we was in and out you feel me in terms
of the vibe of Australia is it like of
an American Vibe or is it like do you
feel like you're in like a whole other
place you definitely feel like you're in
a whole different place yeah just even
driving by certain sides or buildings
the infrastructures are buildings
everything just looked different so
Melbourne is your favorite City you've
been to yeah so far just the people
outside of everything just the way they
embraced us the way they actually
genuinely was fans we did like an after
party after it was cracking like
everybody that came to the show was at
the after party too it was lit any tour
stuff coming up this year uh it's gonna
be a light year I feel like I I
definitely
am dedicating this year to be more
creative you feel me finishing my debut
album yeah but I'm gonna do select dates
different festivals and College shows
things like that so I'm still outside
but we're not even considering you
having any albums out yet
anyways it is yeah yeah call it what you
want but I I feel like I haven't put out
an album yet like I haven't sat down and
genuinely been like album mode
everything I've been making been on the
move so like now you put out the four
pack just to kind of appease everybody
you're like yo I got these four you did
it before obviously yeah uh this is kind
of the appetizer to the debut albums the
appetizer and you could tell too I'm
staying true to my sound right but for
the for the album it's gonna be more
experimental it's definitely still
staying true to myself for the album too
but it's an elevator version of that so
I'm excited for the fans so I feel like
they can predict what I'm doing but I'm
gonna hit them with a left jab real
quick I was gonna say how are you
experimenting because I do feel like
you have your signature sound yeah you
have your I feel like you have your
pocket if we think of like what a blast
BPM is like we kind of know what your
pocket is how are you expanding the
sound how are you experimenting yeah
well for me it's just opening my mind to
different creators as well right A lot
of the times I'll be in the house by
myself like it's only so much
inspiration you can pull from a bedroom
in isolation right right so I'm opening
uh my mind with different writers
different producers different creatives
even just people with good conversation
I'm just you know putting myself more
out there I'll be to myself a lot so you
know it's a challenge for me but I'm
willing to go over that hump would you
say you're an introvert uh I'm like an
introverted extrovert like if you know
me you know I'm goofy you know I'm
actually talking and playful but you
know the people I'm not really
comfortable with it may take some time
for me to get open with you you and
Riley Rich are very similar definitely
yeah yeah we just we just shot the video
to passionate and I was like y'all got
to open up more he was like you know we
two [__] yeah
[Laughter]
it's good people yo this is an amazing
jacket shout out to Jeff Hamilton you
said this is a custom Jack Hamilton Jeff
Hamilton man we did a you know a custom
piece for the before you go to our merch
so fans bought this too yeah what's that
at least a rack 1200 1500 you feel that
I love it man no I know listen I know
regular he made his son's jacket and I
put it on at my boy shop guest list in
Phoenix
and then he was like it's 1200 and I
took it right off and put it back I said
yes shout out to Jeff man shout out Jeff
man he good people